he says hallelujah knowing him for years
uh-huh we don't understand this that's
fine
why i didn't understand
he became a billionaire
have you ever met tyler perry
no
but he's one of my biggest influence
would come to business eye because when
i started the music business i had
people like a jay-z or the
uh cash money or master p or 50 cent
that structure but when i came in the
film business i was like yeah i don't
own nothing
yeah i don't own none of your films but
tyler perry showed me
the industry way to do it so he's my
biggest blueprint of how to truck your
business and own your catalog
and so he's yeah he's a great guy
so when you first you know maybe you saw
a tyler perry film
how did you start researching him to
really dissect how he does things i
didn't have to research he he it was boo
like videos everywhere when he was
before we had all this a lot of his um
plays and movies with bootleg so it was
everywhere he had plays in new york so
he was just everywhere so he was like oh
this is how you do it this is how you
because he was he's really the only
filmmaker african-american where i know
that that have a large catalog
like his kids are fine it's people that
own these films but his catalog of
ownership is
just like the medea catalog is just
alone just
ridiculous i've never seen this done
before so it was amazing
so did you say i want to do the same
types of films or you had your own spin
on yeah my own vision i just wanted i
didn't want to be one of filmmakers that
does all those 100 studio films but i
own nothing
so i'm big on ownership only so you got
to own something like it don't make no
sense that
auto directors those auto films
you know no ip
like it don't make no sense like i don't
i don't even
fan them how how you could work and do a
whole bunch of films and on anything
like i read the article with sylvester
stallone
and he was talking about how he don't
own nut in the rocky franchise he had no
ownership i was like how did this happen
but back then you know he didn't have
the right people around him but he did a
article recently he complained about it
that he doesn't i mean he get paid but
he does the own no ip of it i forgot who
owns it um but he doesn't own so in my
film when i heard that lola is a
franchise i own the whole franchise um
but you gotta you know i'm big on
ownership don't make no sense to me like
when you watch jason
jason in space
jason goes to manhattan like
they don't the person that really did
jason do not own this ip that does the
movies like that so i'm big on ownership
you have to own something
what if someone says
i'm going to give you
this amount of money to sell
this lola franchise this little idea
this this character
and
you won't own it you're going to sign
over your rights but you're going to get
x amount of dollars whatever that makes
sense so like lola one little two have
ownership in it um but i just have to
make sense
i just have to make it have to make some
type of sense but um right now
no nobody
so if it doesn't make dollars it doesn't
make sense yeah you gotta make sure that
makes sense even if even if i say hey
here's some ownership i'd do another
franchise but it gets it don't make
sense to do like i'd be seeing
filmmakers make like a hundred films you
know on one movie like one so i'm big on
ip because but most somebody's only
thinking about ip
like all those big studios got ninja
turtles ip star wars marvel like that's
heavy ip catalog but most filmmakers
don't understand that but you got to
look at legacy you know when i'm not
here
i want to give my kids something
i don't want to give them hey your dad
was a great filmmaker
but i'm broke so
i want to give passing down
do you have kids not yet my wife is
working on kids now oh okay all right
okay
if if
um your son or daughter wanted to be a
filmmaker would you
say great okay
how much do you know about tyler perry
and how he got his start i know
everything
when i look at somebody that i relate to
i really studied him like he his story
is
when they make his movie it's it's it's
going to be amazing but your history
he's just he's one of one he's like a
one percenter you know if you go
research um someone did it before him
was years ago uh i always mess up his
name
asha mache i probably mess up the name
but yeah i can research it ashley mache
he's one of the black filmmaker and back
in the day his films didn't want to take
it so he started his own studio stopped
using his own films
and um yeah so todd perry is like
my mirror to go to when it comes to
ownership and building your own empire
like i said it's okay to give some films
away but own something
and tyler perry was homeless at one time
he was homeless i was homeless
so how much
does does that factor in because you
know how in the film industry it seems
like a lot of people come from
um you know more of a a middle-class
helped background and i know i get some
flashbacks
and and so and and people can be mad if
they want but but that does set a
foundation that does help you
you know whether it's just parents know
somebody and they can get you a job
somewhere um how much does that help you
relate to that person when you see that
they they came from humble beginnings or
i don't even know what his family
situation was like i don't know why he
ended up homeless but well he has seen
family i had broken family he got
molested
um
when i was younger i went through
some of that um but yeah you come from
some people when you come from that
trauma
it's two things gonna happen you're
gonna die in trauma or gonna turn your
pain into purpose he turns pain into
purpose he helped a lot of people so
he's one of the people that i look up to
and influence in my life
and so he initially started doing plays
he was on plays about the church or the
church and
what he taught me is know your audience
he had a huge onus like a rev hughes
and um he just knew his market
and when i'm i'm looking at certain
things he's like one of him 50 cent um a
few other people but him and 50s the two
people that we look up to
in terms of what tyler perry's been able
to build what's the top inspiration for
you he did it
he did it with no help
i mean he had help but he he didn't come
from
the beginnings of family hey i know this
person in that studio i can give you a
job he literally
got it out the mud
he started with nothing and he built
this amazing empire to help a lot of
people so
that's why i look at it because at the
end of the day it's easy to be oh i did
all this stuff who'll help you
like i have a friend that he brags about
but his father works for a big studio
so you take his dad away
his story when her story gonna end
because he don't have that drive
so that's why there's tala
people like tyler perry
the 50 cents in the world and everybody
they come from beginnings i can relate
to
well i mean and in fairness to people
who do come from
you know more of a a money background
it's not their fault it's not their
fault and they can't help it but it's
also what they do
with
the opportunities that they're given
because i've seen both you know some
people take it and they run with it and
that's great and then others it seems
like
they don't and i think that's the
frustrating part yeah for people that
don't come from that because they're
like
you're wasting this you know and it
makes you
angry not just jealous but it's just
like that's that's wasted yeah when i
look at it i tell people at times you
come for nothing you come from a lot of
money
at the end of the day it's all about
execution
i know people that would have a lot of
money they ain't doing anything so it
really comes down to you so
don't let your beginning don't let your
family and friends that have money you
if you really want it you're gonna do it
no matter where you come from
so i know friends that i've been looking
after like
how what what like you have all of this
like what but i realized at the end of
the day that's in your dna the hustle
like
the house is so separate
you have everything you want the house
is so separate and that house is going
to get you to the next level
like look at 50 cent for example
50 cent they don't know if curtis 50
jackson
um
his beginnings everybody nobody got shot
blackboard that stuff
what he was able to do at stars network
no one could never do this he took a
network that no one cared about like i
had stars i didn't know what stars was i
was like why am i paying for this no one
knew about this thing
he took this network and turned into his
own marvel
i never seen a drama series break off in
different series like like it's marvel
like what he did was just incredible so
once again it's producers have been in
the industry for years
they can't do what he do it's in his dna
the house is so separate
what is the hustle
passion
anything necessary
execution
uh
do what you have to do to get where you
want to go
and get out your comfort zone and don't
settle for less
but then going back to that party where
people were enjoying themselves and in
ways that
sometimes people think it's just one
weekend and they'll be fine they can
walk away from it and then if you've
ever been on the other side of that you
see that that one weekend is going to
turn into months and years like me i
don't smoke i don't drink
i barely go to parties because
i'm at point my life right now that i
don't have time to have a whole weekend
partying i could be doing something else
it's okay to do and dab but don't have
to party but your whole life
so any means necessary does not mean
enjoying and joining for one weekend
when it could it could catch you yeah it
means necessary is
if you have a film project
like for me for example right it means
necessary
lola
um
when i could get investments i did
always talk about my job
i don't like my job but i did what i had
to do i worked at my regular job i did
what i had to do i didn't wait i just
did what i need to do and i saved up my
money one of my 401k and invested in my
movie
oh wow okay so anyway necessary you it's
it's
we have too many options now it's no
more gatekeepers
you don't order people on tick tock and
youtube and instagram that's making
their way and making money and paying
for their family no more gatekeepers no
one can tell you no
the only gatekeeper is a person remember
and that was for lola one yeah okay one
of my projects majority of my projects
those two
my new movies the first film that i had
a producer really paid for everything
but um but yeah most of my films i
funded
what are the things that you've learned
from reading and watching
tyler perry
as an artist and a business person that
anything is possible but that you that
you have taken on like like specific
things not just anything is possible
um
only your content
trust in your vision
um
loving yourself first
don't listen to the industry
um because tyler perry he's just not
getting flowers they the hollywood he
says hallelujah knowing him for years
uh we don't understand this that's fine
why didn't he understand
he became a billionaire
so it's noise
you look at you know hollywood was it
made for african-americans it just
wasn't
so
a lot of times like the image just
passed abroad complaining oh the enemies
it wasn't made for you it's like being
in a relationship
if you're a person keep cheating on you
and disrespecting you
don't go home leave so we have to
realize that
though auto industries all those
structures wasn't made for us
um so if they're not made for you make
your own go somewhere else
it's no one gate you could go to there's
so many other options that's nothing you
taught me
options
when
the big networks that you're trying to
go you're trying to pitch your film or
picture project they say no it's okay
but when they say no it's not really no
it's no right now because they can't see
the vision
so when when we know that something is
not right for us like an industry
and there's hashtags that say whatever
oscar's so white or whatever and so we
know that
but then at some point though they go oh
yeah i like that and you see like okay
now they need us or now they need our
picture
what do you say to that okay i'll play
this time
this is up to you it's the individual we
play this time write a bigger check it's
all up to you
but at the end of the day eventually
they come around you can't like top her
make so much noise now they're coming
around so this is this is part of it
so though what's that one saying oh be
so whatever that they can't ignore you
yeah okay that's what he did he like
now they can't you know now he's working
with netflix
so
eventually they even gonna come now they
come later but they're gonna come
if you build it they come
okay but then don't don't expect
do do it your way and then when they're
ready then they'll show up whether it's
music
yeah it doesn't matter don't wait like
don't don't be there knocking on the
door and wasting 100 years knocking on
the door and say please i wanted to see
at the table when you build your own
table the food tastes better
so
build your own table like back in the
day i get it back in the day was hard
now you make phones you make moves on
your iphones you can just do so many
options now that you don't need it
you